James Caratini est ancien professeur de
techno il est directeur de l'association
science réunion pour la diffusion de la
culture scientifique mais il est avant
tout un plongeur passionné de
photographie sous-marine auteur de
plusieurs ouvrages sur la faune
subaquatique ces images ont souvent été
primées lors de festival de photos
sous-marine il collabore aussi avec le
Muséum d'Histoire Naturelle la Faculté
des Sciences l'Aquarium de La Réunion ou
encore le parc marin il partage
aujourd'hui avec nous sa passion lors
d'une plongée sur la passe de l'Ermitage
je suis arrivé à l'Î de la réunion il y
a à peu près 25 ans j'étais déjà très
très très orienté photographie mais
notamment terrestre et en arrivant à l'
de la Réunion Mo j'ai je me suis tout de
suite équipé j'étais plongeur et j'ai
pris le virus de la photo sous-marine
donc il y a 25
ans
on est passé par par des stades de de
gros gros travail de prise de vue et et
de de vraiment un travail sur sur la
lumière sur sur la composition sur sur
l'analyse de l'image et sur l'analyse
vraiment des réglages à quelque chose de
beaucoup plus simple actuellement je
dire un photographe maintenant qui a
juste un bon regard grâce à nouvelle au
nouvelles technologies peut progresser
beaucoup plus plus vite qu'à
l'époque sur une pellicule on avait pas
un rendement énorme actuellement bon
c'est simple on efface voilà c'est c'est
c'est super je trouve c'est super pour
pour pour démarrer actuellement la photo
sous-marine on perd plus de temps on
voit tout de suite son résultat sous
l'eau donc on peut tout de suite
corriger donc on arrive à sortir tout de
suite des photos sur une Plée
quoi
c'est vrai que c'est une activité où il
faut il faut il faut pas aller trop vite
sur cette partie là de se dire je plonge
je fais de la photo tout de suite il
faut quand même passer par un stade de
formation les clubs sont là pour ça donc
arriver à à bien maîtriser la plongée
avant tout avant de commencer à
envisager de faire de
l'image
les image qu'on a pu faire ce matin
alors on est parti dans des conditions
un peu difficiles vous avez pu constater
et et on se rend compte que on a eu
beaucoup de chance parce qu'on on est
parti sur un site où du du coup il y
avait personne on s'est retrouvé qu'à à
deux à deux plongeurs sous l'eau sur un
site qui est quand même très très prisé
donc la passe de l'Hermitage et du coup
on sent tout de suite quand il y a pas
trop de monde parce que bah les animaux
sont plus calme ils sont on va dire
presque plus
réceptifs le monde du silence c'est pas
pour rien donc ça fait du bien de temps
en temps de se retrouver justement un
peu un peu tranquille et et puis faire
de l'image bon ben c'est c'est une façon
son aussi de de de communier avec la
nature de l'animalier c'est toujours
quelque chose c'est c'est c'est un don
de la nature on va dire parce qu'on peut
très bien faire une plongée pas voir
grandchose ce matin c'est c'était
c'était que du bonheur quoi vraiment
magnifique